[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
me
[Music]
every city has its secrets
lima is no different
over the last decade
a new criminal enterprise has taken root
but how they work and who they are is a
mystery to me
and i'm not the only one looking for
them
this footage is from the peruvian
national police
who have turned up the heat
and turned lima into the front lines in
the war on counterfeiting
that's how i landed here
at lurigancho prison one of the most
dangerous prisons in all of south
america
the peruvian national police tipped me
off to a counterfeiter they recently
nabbed
and then they'd been chasing for years
he's wearing a mask for two reasons he
doesn't want to be known as a snitch in
prison and he doesn't want his young
daughter to know that he's locked up
he's told her that he's taken a job
abroad
incredibly it's estimated that sixty
percent of all fake u.s bills are
produced in peru
armada
he says it was an informant that
ultimately got him busted by the police
but the hunt for this man
actually began 3 500 miles north
[Music]
two weeks earlier i paid a visit to the
secret service
the agency we associate with these guys
in crisp suits protecting the president
is also in charge of protecting our
money
when fakes are detected anywhere in the
world they're sent here
for the monetary equivalent of an
autopsy
i watch as analysts examine each of the
bill's component parts
the paper
the ink
the colors
within each fake hides clues about its
origin
telltale markers are discovered
the chemical makeup of a certain ink or
the density of a certain paper stock
each bill then gets catalogued helping
the secret service identify the world's
biggest players in the counterfeit game
what happened in the early 2000s the
first peruvian produce note started
popping up and in peru there were no
counterfeit laws at the time it just
caught her by surprise that it started
there
this field agent wants to remain
anonymous for safety reasons he tells me
the agency first opened a lima office in
2012 because the counterfeit scene was
booming these guys are artists the
workmanship's there and then the skills
are there it's being produced at high
numbers and very high quality tonight
the real cost of fake money officers
want everyone to be on the lookout after
a batch of bad bills has turned up in
the city another counterfeit money bust
in limestone county when it comes to
counterfeiting it's pretty much crime
that hurts everybody
from nations economies to businesses to
your mom-and-pop stores things that are
being passed that are worthless
you're at the bank and they see it look
at you you're the criminal it's almost
like a mugging that you didn't know
happened
[Music]
we tend to think of black markets as a
world apart but the truth is they're all
around us
hidden in plain sight
difficult to see
until someone lets you in
that's especially true when tracking
this counterfeiting story in lima
the leads are literally everywhere
seemingly everyone has been a victim of
fake bills
with the walls of some shops looking
like a gallery for the city's criminal
artisans
in a cash society like peru anywhere
money changes hands is an opportunity
for a counterfeiter
[Music]
and nowhere does more money change hands
than here among limas cambistas or
street side money changers
sometimes it's the customer trying to
slip fake bills to the cambista
and sometimes it's the other way around
the vistas the the man is changers
i never go to those
you never know what's real and what's
fake
it's a very murky world
put it away
i contact my friend fernando lucena he's
a local investigative journalist who
said he could get me in touch with one
of these crooked cambistas
the man i'm meeting is akin to a
neighborhood drug dealer
he's my entry point to the underworlds
i'm hopeful he might introduce me to
some of the bigger players in the game
the ones moving millions in fake bills
into the u.s
is
[Music]
[Laughter]
you just asked me if i was a buyer
if i was an undercover buyer
he's gonna show us some of the fake
dollars that he sells
let's play with
this looks pretty
great to me
though this sounds like money to me no
pull the bill out turn it over
feel it
there's texture it's rough and smooth
there's a watermark security thread
layers and layers of detail
each element presents a new challenge
for counterfeiters
but the better their handiwork
the more they can charge
and the more their services will be in
demand
so
touch look and turn
we all have intimate relationships to
money
we chase it we spend it we save it we
make big life decisions because of it
and yet it's so common i've never really
looked at it
the best fake bills are so exquisitely
crafted
they aren't noticed at all
um
[Music]
before the money changer left he
confirmed what the secret service told
me in dc
that once the designs for the fake bills
have been produced there are essentially
three key positions in any
counterfeiting operation
the printer who is the master artisan in
charge of bill production
the finisher who adds the necessary
texture and polish to the bills to make
them passable
and the barrier who transports the fake
cash out of the country
i want to find all three something an
outsider has never done before
it's the best way for me to fully
understand the inner workings of this
black market
and the circumstances and motivations of
the people who run it
[Music]
enter another of my contacts
a local producer who shares a nickname
with peru's national dish
ceviche
over the last several years he's been
building connections in lima's
underworld
specifically through a man we'll call
diego
ceviche tells me that the counterfeiting
racket in lima is run by a handful of
families
and diego's gotten tight with one of
them
each of these families controls
underground workshops where old school
offset printers churn out sheets after
sheet of fake bills
criminal organizations bound by blood
are notoriously difficult to penetrate
getting inside one of these operations
especially with cameras is next to
impossible
in this business there are always risks
but i felt okay with a daytime meeting
hopefully somewhere public
that is assuming they call
three hours pass and still
nothing from diego
[Music]
when the adrenaline kicks in i know
things are about to get good
[Music]
we're on our way to meet with a gang of
peruvian counterfeiters in one of the
shadier neighborhoods in lima
[Music]
they're waiting for us already
with the location change we'll be late
to the meeting
part of me wonders if these guys are
looking for an excuse to bail on us
mema's counterfeiters are extra skittish
these days
i would be too if i was being hunted
there have been a series of huge busts
recently
including one only days before we
arrived that intercepted five million
dollars in fake bills the peruvian
national police gave us this footage
it wasn't at all what i'd expected
i'd imagine these counterfeiting
operations happening in warehouses or
factories and dark corners of the city
but much of it seems to be happening in
residential neighborhoods on quiet
streets inside garages hidden in plain
sight
[Music]
okay
for obvious reasons we couldn't record
this initial meeting but let me tell you
how it all went down
i've been on a lot of these underworld
first dates over the last 15 years
[Music]
you never know exactly what you're
walking into
[Music]
at an outdoor cafe diego introduces us
to the boss and his bodyguard who is
covered in tattoos
one on his arm reads in english only god
can judge me
the mood is tense suspicious
as i always do in these situations
i order beers
[Music]
soon after i'm sharing my unofficial
resume photos on my phone of me hanging
out with men like these from all around
the world
then the food arrives
more talk
more drinks
i then explain that i've heard they're
the most talented counterfeiters in the
world
you'd be surprised how many doors
flattery can open
i knew i'd passed the test when the
bodyguard gave me a nickname he pointed
at me from across the table and said
mirena my queen
you're gonna see amazing things tomorrow
night
in any city there are people who play by
the rules and people who don't
usually it's hard to tell the difference
finding my way into the criminal
underworld
is always an adventure
that's why i love what i do
it's also knowing that once you're in
you get to witness what very few
outsiders ever do
a universe governed by its own laws and
power structures
that teaches us a whole lot about our
own
systems
[Music]
okay
game time
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
oh in peru like many places in central
and south america gringos is synonymous
with americans
in this case the counterfeiters are on
guard that any gringos could be secret
service agents trying to infiltrate
their operations
[Music]
[Music]
hello
they've told us to meet them here at a
downtown park
ironically only blocks from the palace
of justice
somewhere in these surrounding buildings
fake money is being made
they've set two rules
only the crew they met with are allowed
inside
and once inside we stay the entire shift
from 8pm to 8 am
no one leaves
i imagine it's a rush to see your net
worth growing with every new sheet of
bills coming off the press
you could print yourself out of debt or
into a new car or a new house
it's not hard to see the allure
or the desperation that would cause
someone to enter this line of work
one hour
no call back from diego
two hours
diego's phone is off
the police
[Music]
things aren't looking good
[Music]
[Music]
it's been over three hours and they
still they haven't shown up and it's
pretty safe to say that
you've been stood up
no chance this is going to happen
tonight
there's nothing worse than getting this
close and not coming home with a story
but giving up isn't an option
they are still out there
and i'm gonna find them
[Music]
stories go cold
sometimes you can't explain it
you make a connection you make plans
things seem to be falling into place
and then you find yourself staring at
your phone for a call that never comes
in these moments i always remind myself
that nothing's changed
the story is still out there somewhere
in the city offset printing machines are
churning out sheets after sheets of fake
dollars
is
[Music]
nothing happens as fast as you want it
to
this isn't the safest neighborhood so we
should try to avoid showing off our
cameras but i have faith that another
door will open
[Music]
they were definitely like saucing
[Music]
until i can find some of these
counterfeiters in the wild
i lean on the contacts i've already made
um
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
okay so he's showing us how he works
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
okay seems that everything is in place
yeah so far is it good
fingers crossed
it's 5 am and my initial contact in lima
fernando has a new lead on a printer who
seems willing to meet with us
we've got this meeting set up in a
illegal printing operation where we're
going to meet a
guy supposedly an ink master and finally
see what these printing operations look
like
well cannon can't read it
what he's told me is basically keep the
team as as small as possible don't call
his name in front of anyone
just give it a low key
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we just want to make actually be
absolutely sure that we play by their
rules because we want to be able to get
this in the bag
everybody's anxious and nervous and
hoping that this is that this will all
go as planned
we park outside a shopping mall and wait
for word from our contact
okay there are two guys walking
is that him
right that just came out
be careful yeah fred if he sees you
[Music]
okay he's here
okay let's go guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and they're just finding big
[Music]
money it's early morning in lima
and the smell of fresh ink is in the air
i found my way to a printer who
specializes in counterfeit us dollars
it's like no underworld scene i've
accessed before
it's so out in the open that i'm
actually nervous for them
wow this is incredible this is amazing i
mean we're in a printing mall uh it's
too early so all the shops are closed so
it's the surreal scene where we walk
down these corridors and everything was
closed and then suddenly there's a
bright light here and they're just
printing fake money
printing is the most daring aspect of
fake note production it's loud it's long
and it's often done in public locations
like this
it's also very difficult it takes years
to learn the secrets of this trade
the inks the paper the machine the
process of forging bills is equal parts
art and science
very few have the right combination of
talents
this is
[Music]
this is the beginning of everything they
do here every single hundred dollar bill
that's done here starts with this metal
plate
and it's essentially the watermark in
the fantasma
these plates are made by coveted
designers and are critical to the whole
operation
[Music]
check this out
all the bills coming out
ah the second part is the off-white
color of every banknote
[Music]
so the whole process takes a month and
no holy
that's a ton of money that is crazy
they can make six million dollars for
the machine that cost them seven
thousand dollars to buy here
the later it gets the more nervous the
printer becomes we can hear other shops
opening voices echoing down the hallway
[Music]
because you can see the 100 bills here
the metal plate so they want to do this
process really fast
wow check this out
this is amazing
we've got the watermark the background
color of the banknote and now franklin's
face
yeah okay
he's hiding everything
they heard there's somebody walking down
the corridors
home soon
we have to go
[Music]
as we head for our van it hits me that
what surprised me most about the printer
is something that also surprised me
about the prisoner
they were both conflicted about their
decision to get into counterfeiting
but both realized that perfecting their
craft
was the best way to stay in demand
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
once the bills come off the printer
there's still work to be done to make a
convincing fake
fernando is able to locate another of
peru's finest underworld artisans the
finisher
his role is to add texture and weight to
the bills so they will pass the touch
look and turn test
we're driving to villa el salvador on
the south side of lima
an area that locals describe as picante
meaning hot
hot with every criminal enterprise you
can imagine
the cops call it
because murder rate is
not
particularly low
[Music]
he's going to show us the stuff that he
just got
so it's a sponge regular
this is for cutting the
notes
to make a straight
[Music]
is
a u.s spends millions and millions of
real dollars to deter counterfeiting
and these counterfeiters get around it
with school supplies
in an effort to look less conspicuous
we plan to meet back up in his workshop
[Music]
we sneak in our cameras in bags
i wonder if his neighbors have any idea
what's happening inside this room
if they only knew
my search for the makers of the finest
counterfeit bills in the world has
brought me to this working-class
neighborhood outside of lima
[Music]
and to this man
they call him the finisher and his
skills are in high demand
[Music]
it's a painstaking process all done by
hand
with a popsicle stick he applies glue
for weight and texture
to get the field just right he adds what
he calls english cornstarch
which
[Music]
good
you can really feel the texture it's
changed
it's amazing
he says he also works on hundreds and
fifties
but twenties are easier to fake and much
less scrutinized
with just a few items you can get at any
corner store and a whole lot of patience
the touch sound and smell of the bills
are totally convincing
is
foreign
[Music]
um
[Music]
it's always fascinating to me how people
end up working in black markets in many
ways counterfeiting is just another
crime of opportunity
a driver by day discovers he has the
extraordinary patience and craftsmanship
to finish bills by night
a printer specializing in calendars and
business cards realizes he can deploy
the same machines and skills to produce
stacks and stacks of fake bills
but all the time and work that goes into
making a convincing fake is worthless
if those bills don't reach the legal
economy
and that's where this man comes in they
call him the burier a peruvian mash-up
formed from the spanish word buro
meaning donkey
and the word courier
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
facebook
counterfeiting networks know that some
portion of their shipments will be
confiscated so they employ an army of
ants who transport fake bills into the
u.s by airplane by car by boat on foot
they even ship fake bills through the
mail
but getting these fake bills into the
country isn't enough
they need to get them into circulation
the counterfeiting game is all about
getting
might do is at changed shopping centers
going down a highway corridor you can
hit malls on the north side of town and
malls on the south side of town one fast
food place one convenience store you
just spend you know eight nine dollars
and then you pay with 100 and that means
you're coming back with you know 90 some
dollars of genuine
real money yeah
you could you know pocket a thousand
dollars by the end of the day and you're
not really doing much
it's like an atm that doesn't belong to
you
when counterfeiters do get busted
their stash of fake bills gets sent to
the secret service
where they're examined
catalogued
used in prosecution
and then destroyed
some of these fake bills are probably
from peru
maybe they even pass through the hands
of the guys i met
but even if the lima scene is shut down
there will be others
m
[Music]
it's an old con and an old truth
if you're desperate enough to make some
money
one option
is to make some money
[Music]
you